what up anime fans its gozen and kid car
and we're here to talk about Dragon Ball
super episode 46 kid car initial
thoughts
well it's interesting let's just put it
this way we washed it without subtitles
we kind of went on a recommended thing
and we kind of read a synopsis but yeah
oh no I think it was from what we made
out we'll it wasn't as bad as the first
one it's gotten better yeah it's gotten
better I don't like the better than the
first two
so what kid Kai wanted to say there was
that we looked at Herms review herbs 98
on Twitter and he's awesome because he
goes out does the translations like
right when the episode comes out like
god bless him like all of us like
wouldn't know what the hell's going on
if it wasn't for him most of the time at
least until the official like not
official but like unofficial sub comes
up but yeah it definitely it wasn't bad
I mean again the humor is for these
episodes it's focused again on on humor
rather than actual good storytelling
like humor is definitely privileged like
we get the fact that Goku and Vegeta are
fighting which is like yes do we get to
figure out who's stronger no not really
because before it ends we have Vegeta
copy Vegeta being destroyed because well
naka accidentally wakes up from his
sleep and steps on the crystal yes and
apparently apparently Monica's stepping
on it is enough to break the nucleus
kind of ridiculous but again it's humor
is amazing yeah yeah for filler we gotta
judgment by humor and and I gotta say I
did laugh my ass off and both me and
kick I did when jackal it's a blob was
about to eat Jocko and that it just
skips them because it's not strong
enough going
Goten trucks that was hilarious well
done on their part yeah there was
definitely one of my favorite parts of
the episode and another favorite
favorite part definitely had to be when
Regina was made to wear a pacifier that
apparently he didn't realize was a
pacifier but that was definitely
hilarious yes and I think it's implied
that it was just a pacifier and didn't
help anything in the slightest bit
but it was the I he said he wasn't a
born if it wasn't pacifier but hey man
you wore it that's funny but going back
to what we talked about earlier Goku vs.
Vegeta I think it might be hinting at
the fact that Goku could be potentially
stronger because we haven't seen him
unleash Kaioken times ten against the
blob and while going Super Saiyan God
Super Saiyan they were marched evenly
yeah but at the same time with the KO
cat like I mean we don't even know if
can do that again without completely
messing up this ki so at the same time
doesn't even matter I mean if you can be
stronger for like a little bit and then
ruin the rest of your future or like you
know yeah but the question isn't whether
you're ruining your future it's whether
you can whoop the Jia's ah yeah the time
period I guess hear the question but
another hilarious part and what probably
shows the pride of the Saiyans better
than anything so far was Vegeta's the
fact that he was torn in this episode he
didn't know if you want to go ku or
Coloma jia to win because clomid geo is
representing his strength too so even
though that would have meant him
disappearing forever he was like trying
to cheer on clover jzuk what you call
yourself me man you suck yeah like he
was it was it was a satisfaction of
rather being yeah and I'm the
satisfaction that he's better than
Kakarot exactly he's been living which
is completely like sand pride at its
finest like you would rather die than
have his clone who represents him lose
the Kakarot which is it's pretty
powerful that's why you didn't know what
to do he was cheering for why he was
cheering for the other he was like you
should do better you should do better
and you know what it was cool it it
shows the kind of character he is and
what sayings represent and he epitomized
the sayings as you know the Prince of
all Saiyans but on the other hand you
also see his human side you see him
again stepping up to the fun drunk
something that maybe you wouldn't have
seen in Dragon Ball Z although I feel
like the Bardock movie kind of suggests
that they would kind of protect their
family members I think you supposed to
be a separate will have to rewash this
but episode yeah we're gonna re-watch it
soon but yeah like what pretty much we
have Vegeta just completely stepping up
as a father and you know watching this
guy's transformation has been one of the
joys of Dragon Ball and Dragon Ball Z
and John Ball super and really you know
I loved it I loved watching him grow as
a human being and him caring for trunks
and it's great and even seeing how
trunks calls him like Papa you know but
Gina is not even he's not even a harsh
dad you know he kind of like seems
standoffish sometimes but really you can
tell by trunks reaction they did really
does love him and that but Gina loves
him in return and that's that's
something cool they wouldn't expect to
see from the cold Prince of Saiyans yeah
I agree his characters definitely
changed it's nice to see him changing
but now we were all so let me get this
in we were also talking about why he
might be called like the Prince of
science even though all the other
sayings are dead yeah yeah and one of
one of our buddies at our barbecue
actually shout out to me high low if
he's listening to this he suggested that
it could be because he wants like show
respect pay respect to his father who
although he died you know he still wants
to respect his position so that could be
like a take on why he contains consoles
princess saying you know he was never
officially inaugurated as king of sands
that could be a simple but you never
know there's a mixture of the I mean he
was before yeah before he was like the
could be the king of sayings the sayings
were kind of wiped out and then it's
like how can you be king you know so
yeah makes sense because he is
technically not Prince working of any
anymore really because they're gone but
still a cool title that yeah of course
Prince of all saying you know why he
takes a lot of great pride and as all he
should but what did you want to say kid
guy okay now I want to get to the thing
that are the thing that we've all been
salivating for and been waiting on for a
while since they've announced that
Future Trunks like the fifteenth twenty
thirty second bit that we get of him in
the end that was exciting and not gonna
lie just watching that was better than
the whole episode almost yeah like that
the short splittin time period that they
gave us for that made me just salivate I
cannot wait for the saga to start this
is a long long long anticipated this
could if this could make super better
finally we get that better yeah one of
the arguably top five most popular
Dragon Ball Z characters and definitely
one of the coolest Dragon Ball Z
characters come back now I have one
question why on earth is is here blue
I'm pretty sure it's purple yeah that's
the thing I didn't get either this heavy
purple like is it trying to imply that
he has like some kind of super saiyan
blue on his own or is it just like did
did writers just be like oh [ __ ] [ __ ]
you know continuity I don't know well I
guess we'll figure that out and that's
something else we can speculate about
his uniform is definitely cool like it's
definitely dope and you know what the
hell what's he running from man like we
heard he's very powerful so I wouldn't
be surprising if you're chief super
saiyan blue on his own yeah but why why
is he running was he running from and
then we found finally have an official
release of black goku picture which is
like kind of pretty much goku with like
a cool earring so yeah is that the pitar
earrings and is yeah so we'll see what
now some people say it's related to the
video games that came out recently the
xenoverse and stuff where they think the
character that McGraw will be
reintroduced because Goku has the same
pitar earrings that
he had and he was a highly popular
character in xenoverse and stuff like
that but here's the thing is I don't
think he's as powerful as beerus or
wheeze while we know that this new
character which most likely will the new
anti villain mostly could be black goku
is most likely going to be stronger than
beerus and perhaps stronger than wheeze
because it is stated that all the gods
potentially including xenos will have to
get involved in this conflict and for
someone to be that's for him to draw and
Zino's as well he's gonna have to be
extraordinarily strong and he's gonna
have to be potentially stronger than
wheeze like that's that's the only way I
can see him drawing in and I can't wait
to spin because in that way then we'll
get a stronger Goku you know I'll get
stronger main characters yeah and then
even even in this part like Goku and
Vegeta agreed to have a next match and
that each one said they'd win so I
definitely want to see them like both
getting better and who is technically
black coke we even though he looks
exactly like Coke without that's gonna
be his name black Goku because Goku of
trunks his time like that that yeah he
died of natural causes that cannot be
washed back by the Dragon Balls so who
is this is this like a tourist thing
from the earlier movies from the tree of
my movie or is this I don't know when
who is this potential sand that's got an
extraordinarily strong that he he makes
super sin blue super sand potentially
running around like a scared little
child yeah so we'll see and we can't
wait any final thoughts k KY yeah all in
all I'm happy we're it wasn't as bad as
I thought the episode it was much it was
improved I feel like they almost heard
some kind of message from me
yeah it's improved we were going through
some kind of filler hell it was like
three episodes or something which is not
too bad I mean considering the fact that
Naruto goes on for like ten months or
over a year sometimes with fillers it's
not bad at all on yeah that's about it
I'll give this episode of five and a
half maybe six out of ten
in terms of in general in terms we'll
give it a five and a half but yeah can't
wait for next week next week is gonna be
super very anticipated if you guys don't
like [ __ ] too and then like you'll be
disappointed it's gonna be a dope
episode I'm sure of it as gonna be a
dope conversation a while since I've
anticipated an anime episode this yeah
I'm anticipating this more than anything
in the let's say super saiyan tournament
know like what is it the universe six
seven tournament arc I'm anticipating
this like way more so it's gonna be yeah
I think I'm anticipating this even in
compared to other anime in general a lot
like I mean this has definitely a lot of
pressure weight and pressure yeah weight
and pressure on them to succeed because
they can't afford for this to be about
there's way too much anticipation it's
drawing in a lot of fans it's drawing
I've heard even fans who haven't been
watching old fans coming back because
just because it's future drugs and
that's all I want to hear super excited
excellent alright guys so we'll see you
next week all right be sure to LIKE
comment and subscribe if you enjoyed
this video and to catch next week's
video this has been goes that and kid
guy we'll see you later space cowboys